ladies and gentlemen to protect present
our next award zuy Zhang
film is a universal language because the
stories are told with images not just
words it's a few editors job to cut
those images into a work of art the
nominees for achievement in film editing
are Mike Hill and then Hanley for
Cinderella Man Claire Simpson for the
constant garner Hughes wind-borne for
Christ Michael come from Munich Michael
Mike Husker for what the line and the
Oscar goes to
here's wind-borne for Christ
this is the first Academy Award a
nomination for a huge wind boy
hi-yah first of all 42 I'd like to wish
my father in North Carolina happy 83rd
birthday secondly Paul Haggis a force of
nature
thank you Paul I would not be here
without Paul I would not be here without
Kathy Schulman and I want to thank both
of you from the bottom of my heart
thanks to Bob yari Lionsgate for seeing
a powerful film thanks to my assistant
Sean Hubbert 9 Jesus thanks to uh I said
name some friends of mine who've
supported me over the years as Donna
Bruce Bob Rock Leslie I can't remember
any of my girlfriend Lula who has gotten
me through the last three weeks that
I've been a the bull believe me
and not last but not least my editing
partner don't start the music I can see
you my editing partner Mike my film
partner my movie buddy my son who makes
my life wonderful every day Wyatt and
I'd like to dedicate my war to a friend
the memory of a friend dan Petry senior
who passed away last year
thank you very much